internet and the citizens of reject
Nation it is time to get back into the
dcau we are back in continuity with Teen
Titans the Judas contract have you seen
this one John I don't know what to
expect is this a Bible crossover some
sort of that's the true crossover the
multiversity Jesus
and then there's Catholic mythology when
they combine that's the theme Universe I
need you know what James Gunn adapt the
Bible that's what we need yeah the King
James it's gonna be great no it's the
Pocket Edition yes sir of course of
course this is gonna be very exciting
please do like and subscribe leave a
comment below with your favorite passage
from the Bible also let us know your
favorite Comic character from this and
also let us know which of these you want
us to do next as you can tell we're
going like left and right we're jumping
around we're going to Injustice we're
coming back remember if you want to
watch all of this including our resting
watches faces
check out the patreon where you can see
this front to back start to finish no
pauses just all the way through and in
the meantime please do enjoy Teen Titans
Judas contract
foreign
[Laughter]
when do I get to drive my car so never
oh I'm gonna sign up this thing called
Twitter
don't do it
flash go find out on it
report you need to see for yourself I'm
not totally sure that was very helpful
Young Flash worth it worth it I also
like that they drive the gorilla's Jeep
Clint Eastwood is not part of the team
it's the 19 2000 video
that's how they meet Starfire first we
stop the Fearsome five and now we get to
stop an alien brawl
which side do we join really
[Music]
[Laughter]
not helpful
foreign
[Applause]
I hope he goes by that here
cause he's not green
whoa
nice Robin
Speedy okay good I was hoping that was
Speedy but he's got a drug problem I
wonder if that comes into play that's
all this movie is gonna be about
special episode yeah
I want you to push these all over
Metropolis
fast like we'll call you speedy
[Music]
great use of powers
whoa
[Music]
foreign
Faith there Robin
is that no I did not see that coming
nope
no no starting on Twitter I am coriander
of tamarin Our Kind can learn language
from the act of kissing ah useful sure
that's a way of so many conflicting
emotions at this moment let me introduce
you to my friends oh by the way I speak
some Spanish if you want to learn that
cool I took Latin so I mean let me
introduce everyone I won't say their
names we'll stand around and this will
be kind of weird it's like guys perfect
opportunity for a little Exposition
right there because I assumed that was
Speedy but not everyone knows Speedy
yeah I was gonna say you saved me the
embarrassment of having to ask you Coy
he literally like one of his most iconic
comic covers is here with like needle
and like the comics code Authority was
like
big big shift there in the comics
cool crane shot took him all night to
set it up
more than your lives capitalism
Amazon that's Bezos
the Titans will be there in less than a
minute I see no signs of that
yeah because they're outside I got a
minute
would they call First why do you think
you'd see I don't know but what are you
thinking lady yeah you better hop into
one of those power loaders
oh
a robin has become a wing well done
Damien they're ready they're slow oh
nope that's Damian Dick's over there
different different Robins
still addicted to Twitter though respect
they're bound to spot us Nightwing if we
wait for those clouds dick terrorists
taking us up there she is yeah I do all
the dirty work around here
oh cause she can terraform she was the
one at the end of the post credit scene
that I didn't recognize people got very
mad at me yeah yeah you screwed up who
am I lost 10 nerd points
for you remember these opponents are
different they'll sacrifice themselves
without hesitation to get to you so the
quicker we take them down the better
very well said golly
it appears they're there now
that was a solid minute thanks for
getting us into the impenetrable Hive
face Tara
you're the best you are the best around
wall punch abandon the base
they've prepared well the reaction time
is much better Robin stop complimenting
the bad guy
Ripley's must buy their bad guy stuff in
bulk
they must because they could just
abandon the base with little concern but
we do that move you taught me last
weekend what will the team think what
no
the training move please
oh
Nightwing you horndog
ah
your service has come to an end
God bless you all I'm in
[Music]
that was unbearable
I've been doing a lot of thinking lately
about what
[Music]
I think we should take the next step in
our relationship oh
[Music]
settling down Nightwing
say cheese
it's almost detective chimp almost one
day we get closer every day
I got an apartment in the city I hoped
maybe we could share you know together
it's not about me but yeah good man no
Rock that's a lame
I'm over a million followers
boy
five years it's a long game
it's true
oh everything I do pisses her off
quit turning into a chimp and stealing
monkey kisses
people think that's adorable not for
much longer
reliving this moment
Danger Room complete is it true what
they say about her
that she has her father trapped in that
Jewel on her head
sure is we saw that
his name's John Bernthal
baby boy are you getting enough to eat
yeah how's it going
Batman's a fascist
I'm working on it Dad it's got a mind of
its own and a temper I'll do you think
Superman or someone could take that
thing off him a different Dexter sounds
kind of like him yeah I'm sorry it's
just
I miss my son
oh rough Zoom real rough Zoom isn't your
church just a glorified cult I believe
it in America where all beliefs should
be treated with respect
it's a shame the Press doesn't
interesting grandfather would have been
impressed with blood running a worldwide
cult as well as Hive do you ever get out
of that uniform only when I bathe might
be time
[Laughter]
I'm good
smells great going out
I hear you're gone a lot
where'd you go
clubbing
in this I go on patrol
by the way I should offer
congratulations on your cohabitation
Grayson
of course
[Music]
something's wrong yeah there is he's
about to be crushed at foosball you want
to come see that's off
punch that grief away those who deny the
chosen have no place in the eating that
shall be built who do not share our
values need not apply brothers and
sisters you were just on TV saying all
belief systems
it's almost like certain Cults are
hypocritical what I mean what a concept
koi I know I know not in America no
it's the separation church and state
this country always that was the third
base the Titans have destroyed my plan
is nine centuries in the making but as
you can see I am always Victorious
oh buddy his heresy does not compare to
the Titan's threat
oh my God it's hostile too in here bring
anything in his blood oh
the center my parents volunteer for the
one in my town maybe I should volunteer
oh besides I gotta find a way to make
the bug more comfortable around humans
a smart and charitable now if you just
find a way to live stream yourself doing
it you got to make sure people know
you're being good wondering who I could
speak to about volunteering that would
be me just because we have powers
doesn't mean we can't you know have
relationships uh
uh she said hi and also she'd help him
I'd love to they're in a relationship
now they're married oh okay got it yep
same as Nightwing and Corey
kill her kill the demon
what's the matter nothing
this is lame I'm out are you seeing the
future or the past
or nearly a millennium I have bathed in
my enemy's blood it has provided me
immortality I have often wondered why
Phyllis Preston Esquire
proceed
[Music]
yes whoa
thank you
[Music]
you've done well
Advance the preparations Mayhem your
service has come to an end
what how
it worked
but also but this is power like what's
the only this part of my head is
vulnerable otherwise the rest of me
she's a good shot are you okay she's
going to bring the building down I can
help
[Music]
what are you doing get off me oh we came
to check on you are you all right it was
a freaking nightmare
just leave me alone
the building was shaking we could have
all died so good to see you again my
friends it's been too long don't make
this weirder than it already is but are
you referring to the setting
it's a place of renewal I have no
problem eating anywhere you want
for no matter how rotted the corpse
there's always a tiny wisp of life left
you of all people should know that
oh buddy
as before I want all the Titans
can you do it
it's a yes Furrow shall we dance good
sir but of course my lady like was there
Ren Fair now
they're LARPing
I guess we know who's taking out the
garbage at the new place
that was not a confidence booster
you did very well you lasted far longer
this time
what every man wants to eat yep always
nice he's very proficient when we have
Corey
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the fish is very very proficient yeah
yeah sure proficient and efficient
these Titans
huh
are you okay nah it's a trick I'm fine
though dad feels I've disgraced myself
oh
all right Batman attacked yep
I'm gonna enjoy shutting you up only if
you catch me mama
whoa
wow cool
Beast Boy is so ready for movies man
it's so cinematic oh yeah let Garfield
give you a big hug So Soft a little kiss
you get what's coming to you
[Music]
I'm sorry it's not my fault
let me calm your mind no don't touch me
it's okay Tara we understand yeah
let somebody help I know you didn't mean
to hurt me I took it too far what's
wrong with you people
uh
teeth stands for tribulations yeah
trials and
Tara needs more training it's something
else she knows t for therapy
if you need to talk let us help you
such an observant considerate boy
they got you to a Lazarus Pit just in
time
yes I've been bathing in it quite a bit
lately
you might say it's addictive sure
improves muscle tone too
new celebrity workout at the pit
[Music]
yeah your friends have made you soft wow
oh
damn it why you betrayed us why
that assumes I was ever on your side in
the first place she did have a very
villain entrance
[Music]
alive yeah I just got Cask of
Amontillado it's a good finishing move
this just reminds me of home
oh egg hi careful
now they're married yes of course my bad
getting ahead of myself I know my pulse
is racing but I'm in no danger none
defensive measures are not needed oh no
it's got that Hulk problem yeah humans
cause sexual attractions
and my life puberty and hormones whole
hell of a thing what are you doing ah
I thought I'd get more comfortable
how many hundreds of years old is she
you damaged the camera lens
it's taken a year to get the information
I need to defeat the Titans stay still
yup yup
whoa
[Music]
believe or die I'm getting out of here I
don't want to go back
the Titans are always acting like they
care so much
with the money from blood will form our
own League of Assassins together in
every way
wow that's Twisted
also like a modern witch trial with guns
somehow feels that much worse so intense
yeah weapons to our new place
don't like them no no they're great
you met with members of the team without
me so they instinctively look to you now
that you're back
after all I'm not even from your world
oh but but you belong have I told you
how glad I am that you've chosen to move
in with me
at least I was your first choice for
that well gara's got his house and Jaime
couldn't afford the rent
plus you're the only one I can kiss
solo he's working on something like out
in movies and shows no one's ever texted
anyone ever before or they always delete
it it's always like the first text of
everything I could teach you some
meditation techniques they might help
you stay in control the other reason I'm
here is to tell you the team's
assembling in the common room come on
Raven you can get through to her they
know I'm working with you if they knew
she wouldn't have come alone unless they
wanted to get my guard down I don't
think I can take them all if they're
ready
call paranoid for undercover work
[Music]
oh no
one year anniversary is a member of the
Titans it was all Raven's idea thanks
oh thanks a lot
try those tears and let's get this party
started mama
let's get a montage going yeah it's time
for Montage with CW songs yeah with
popular music amongst the youth that's
what they use to listen to
no
coyotes undercover fun that scientist
used to work for Hive Beast Boy sending
you pictures of terrorist party
two trapped in the earth why not get me
out of here so I can defend myself
properly you're down to hoping I'm Gonna
Act Like the biggest stooge in a b movie
your outfit said give it a shot
bit stroke you cost me my rightful place
you took my old family Damien
so I'll take your new one eye for an eye
he's already got one gone yeah I am well
and we'll see you soon
you're more of a
[Laughter]
don't bother me it's a shame I don't
have more time to break you down
inside a month I'd have you bring me my
pipe and calling me Papa
oh you seeing this and if we do find the
scientist we want him alive at all costs
we leave in five minutes
I wonder if Deathstroke realizes the
humor in calling Damien a
hope so innate you know Brotherhood
comedy
thank you
it looks so fun to skate on a big chunk
of Earth
[Music]
it's a trap yes
any idea what that Gizmo is nothing good
he's deleting I vote we stopped that
that makes two of us
[Music]
majority but fine
we're talking
step away from the computer you won't be
hurt
[Music]
could have just knocked him out you know
yeah
rolly pulley bug into gorilla I know so
many great combos
[Music]
come on
oh
go after him I'll cover you
that's why she's the leader yeah
oh you want to play
seemed a bit excessive but I respect
nice what do you want to ask him first
oh
[Music]
a young Jenna Malone would have been a
great Raven oh great call yeah time
travel casting damn
that we couldn't speak with him about
these
those picks from the carnival from uh
first movie yeah that's right I like
that tie-in they're like two years
younger I like that nothing like laser
spewing Hive drones to take you out of
the party mode
I've been invited to be on Kevin Smith's
podcast at metrocon tomorrow
Smith is Canada is Canada DC Animated
Universe
we all need to be extra vigilant and not
take any chances it's Kevin Smith
[Music]
hahaha
I get a beast boy it's exciting yes
I have a feeling whatever blood is
planning tonight is just a Prelude uh
that's what I'm hoping for man like they
gotta have him like rush out in mid
panel or something this is so good don't
let all that talk back there shake you
up you know I got your back it's other
stuff
like what
I'm all ears
you have a pretty smile
oh do you know how I became an orphan
uh your parents died
yes
oh God after I got powers they freaked
that's so good excellent tact it can be
a bond you know
every one of the teams had it rough
drama Bond aside from an unhealthy
online presence you're normal
yeah you wouldn't change it if you could
you like the attention
sides
it looks okay on you oh you too Teen
Titans Bond no
times kiss oh Teen Titans
oh making her go Super Saiyan there
Beast Boy nice nice little scene
[Music]
I mean I guess it's gotta be nice to
have someone that excited about you so
either she's not a teen and that was
creepy or she is a teen and that's
creepy towards like I have no idea which
thing I'm supposed to be creeped out by
because if she's in a like 30s or 40s
and that stroke's fine but
don't worry they're going to explain all
oh yeah
[Music]
MetroCard when are you hosting I gotta
get there
is Harley Quinn
that's where I was when I missed uh all
those trailers for blue beetles right
other guy
is it Ralph Garmin is it Mark Bernard
Bernard yeah
use
little word there's no audience there
God and per your orders I'll check on
Jaime gar
I think you should pick something up on
the way back
it's okay you got time to practice
I don't trust it I don't trust any of
this
you know he wasn't nearby Jaime
[Music]
oh no
thank you
yeah put it together
no he tased him in the butt that's not a
way you want to go
[Laughter]
oh come on Dar yeah dude never press the
big red button that says do not press no
Corey you here
Corey
[Music]
I'm here to take you to them
weapon wall yeah stays ready
good thing we didn't take these to the
mall for Discount sales Aikido needs
work your spacers for
I like that Deathstroke's finally
Deathstroke in this yeah
oh
nah damn it
oh wow
thank God for that giant pile of garbage
after this the Titans and the Justice
League will Overlook any garbage
violations for safety these are
strategically placed near all their
secret identities homes enough
screw this
oh
my guy had to have a suit underneath
though are we gonna do ramakrishna all
over again it's time you could have died
by the blade with honor Grayson
loser loser
come on D hey
that's why you you check the body
[Music]
it's a big plank of wood
sure why not sometimes that's what I
just wear yeah you know I'm gonna start
doing a wooden plank on your chest
oh way up Martin rig style back into
place good as new he's lying to you
about everything he kept you isolated
dependent
told you everyone was your enemy yep and
promised you exactly what you wanted
believe me I know yeah story of my life
geez
I've always hated you the Titans treated
you like family and you throw it all
away we gave you Coronas
perfectly normal to have feelings for
them but after this we can be together
just like you wanted
just like you wanted you groomer
[Music]
the only picture in my phone that's it
the one that read all the texts all the
images these so-called heroes are
nothing but secular idols
the one true God yes
oh
guys Raven's not moving and something's
keeping me from using my powers to more
yeah she's doing that
his voice is great yeah it really is
what have you done to Robin
and beat the crap out of him for being
Mophie
come on you've all had the urge
can I introduce you to my assistant I
think you've met
thank you
oh she's got a spiky haircut we took you
in helped you now you're gonna die
Tara
it's okay you can fix her yeah
I know this is one of their Vans but I
really wish it was the Turtle van that's
the crossover time back into the Batman
that's how they get saved Teen Titans
and turtles like that would be perfect
it's right there imagine how much pizza
yes
Teenage Mutant Ninja Titans I like the
Nightwing just poked out to look at the
camera just for us
hello it's me it's a me you wanted the
Titans and here they are not all of them
not Nightwing
our contract is not complete
shoot his contract ah there's still a
path to the South
don't you agree
dude
jump in throwing her in there she goes
wow dude oh
uh
I should have charged more with her
powers you're getting an upgrade 12.
huh
amen
foreign
[Music]
oh my no God is going to save you
Deathstroke whatever you're gonna do to
him do it quickly yeah
they're crafty
when their powers are transferred and I
Ascend to God's State hail me
I feel it
yes Brother Blood
[Applause]
oh hell brother Nightwing that's right
brother Justice
[Music]
wow
I knew you'd come
whoa wow
he's a super stroll yeah
[Music]
I am Pastiche man
hey papa here's your pipe
yeah that comeback was great Boogie
wow sound design
what's up
wave your cape at him
[Music]
you need her so you're all a team
so cool don't you know
chosen
no I
died
[Music]
what was that yes what was that
I'm gonna kill you
Hell hath no fury
he took it on two Robins full fight
oh it's between you and me
[Music]
find another Lazarus Pit boy oh
you will die
yes black green Phillip
guys stop it
there we go that's wonder where she was
let me show you one
Azarath Metreon
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh wow
whoa I was destined can't you see I am
blood
ha ha ha
I won't let them cage you my love wow
[Music]
mind your surroundings I think you
sliced a boulder in half too it's a good
sword very good
get him
so long kid whoa
[Music]
Tara I'm sorry
wow smoosh
[Music]
Cersei Lannister
no we have to go the place is gonna
collapse buddy
[Music]
how do you become a Titanic
my man
I'm so happy yep yep oh in the jersey
and all
come on
oh it's not just about the cool
superpowers it's about us helping each
other grow be better people
oh it's a puppy
oh
little Ace bat pup there's a new girl
right all I can say is that she's a
wonderful addition to the team
down a Troy there's no way Starfire is
listening to this man she's brushing her
hair
what was the Daffy Duck too little
Warner Brothers crossover is she gonna
like replace Tara
Dave
there are a lot of people who get handed
a rough life
they never asked for it oh
when the chips were down
and she finally showed her true self
Tara Markov was like a diamond the most
beautiful thing that I'd ever seen
damn dude
yeah oh Christina Ricci was tear it down
interesting and Brandon Sue who from the
From Dusk Till Dawn TV show that's
underrated it was David zayas from
Dexter and Meg Foster was in there too
damn
all right so yeah I I'm very curious
about this Gap in my Titans knowledge
because George Perez era was my jam and
Marvel wolfman's a genius of this world
so I'm gonna have to do some reading see
I feel like if I was you just
hypothetically I would be kind of giddy
when I find like a thing that I haven't
seen because you'd she read and seen so
much that I feel like it's almost yeah
it's like most people you'd be like oh
damn like my cred but I'm like nah you
get it's like a little Discovery now
well because like if you it's hard to
jump into new fandoms because there's so
many things you could dive into people
are always like you should watch this
anime you should watch this or do this
and I'm like I just do but when it's a
thing I'm familiar with then it's not as
overwhelming because I can just like
focus in yeah so I like finding new
things in my own little like you know
wheelhouse yeah uh that was fun that was
fun uh not my not my top half I would
say um but like very glad to have seen
it
um I'm curious when we're gonna strongly
disagree with you that's true that's
gonna be interesting yeah because I
think this is in the bottom half but
like not for any specific reason just
because so many are exceptional yeah
yeah I like this I I really enjoyed this
this this felt
and it's not a slight like this this
felt more oriented toward like the story
it was telling to some degree in the
emotionality at least of the
the Titans I do feel like the stuff with
blood is a little bit like ah you know
he's a big bad dude and when you cut to
him this the scenes look cool and you
know these guys bathing in Blood and
he's you know like in these really
pictures and he's got his cult like that
stuff was like really interesting to to
it I wanted more flesh on that basically
I had no investment any villain in this
yeah
there's something you know what I mean
like there's there's usually an
investment in both sides so you're at
least curious about the villainy yeah
but like I I found Deathstroke cool but
his plan was very much like contract
like there was no yeah there was no meat
on that bone and then the bad guys just
like religion and like that was like
they're they're very like singular so as
much as I enjoyed it I think a big
problem was I just couldn't invest
deeper than like well that's what they
are yeah exactly and there are certain
things that you oh oh I talked to the
dead for no matter how rotted the corpse
there's always a tiny wisp of life oh
who's he gonna be oh
oh
cool it's another comic I don't know I'm
sure there's someone reading the Marvel
Wolfman comic killing me right now
um just looking over the topic toys
right here it's in the literature uh but
yeah for me it like you know I love the
Titans so I was invested in them but
when you're only invested in one side
you can't have a full experience yeah
absolutely like I thought the most fun
stuff and the and the richest stuff was
everything happening
was the dramatic stuff with the Titans
and the light stuff with the Titans like
everything with the with Dick and
Starfire moving or it's just a Corey
Right Moving in like was really fun and
nice and I did like it caught me off
guard a little bit at the top but I
liked having that prologue of like okay
here's Dick's time in the Titans and how
Corey got here and yeah I really like
the real origin of that and then you
know okay going okay so who's still on
the team and now who is uh you know uh
or wait was there a different Beast Boy
in the past no same Beast Boy okay so
he's just an older he's going yeah yeah
he was like one of the youngest of the
DC heroes so he's a kid kid and then
like Speedy you know got into drugs so
he's not in the team that's where he
went oh my goodness but like that was a
green arrows basically Robin was Speedy
like it was his sidekick
um so yeah it was cool to see like other
team members in the past it was also
cool to like see the evolution of their
Dynamic
um but I I don't know I just something
didn't grab me to stay with everything
the whole time I kept finding myself
like aware I was watching something yeah
because there's a thing where you you
get the Tara tease at the end of the
previous Titans versus Justice League
and here she's already part of the team
which is fine but I I almost feel like
for her involvement in the plot and
obviously the twists with her the true
nature of of you know her uh role in the
Titans and her role with uh Deathstroke
and everything I felt like there could
have been some kind of
I don't know like not that I would trade
that original prologue uh but I felt
like there could have been some thing of
like okay we're we're in do inducting
her onto the team you know rather than
just jumping in where she's already on
the team but she seems to hate just
everybody and not be about any of this
and it also feels like the only
relationship you're supposed to like is
Dick and Corey's because like the Beast
Boy like he's kind of annoying like and
gar is being a pest there's there should
be an endearing undertone to it that
never really felt as big as the
pestfulness sure and then like obviously
the Deathstroke relationships was weird
so like you're not really know what to
make out of that because like I assume
she's a teenager and like homeboy is
like 50. so like what in the middle yes
you literally mean you're not a child
like you're just not under the age of
11. yeah I don't know what so like all
the relationships are like how do we
root for you know this Dynamic yeah
because you can't you can't have your
cake and eat it too and be like well she
looks like a teenager but she's like 400
years old or something or or you know
know even just adult age it can't be
because the guard relationship like that
moment was sweet but it didn't it wasn't
really earned and then the end I'd
almost argue like the last three minutes
was very very powerful when Melancholy
and like but it didn't feel as earned
because I just didn't connect to the
point where that should I should have
been a little bit more impactful for me
yeah I really wanted I think if we were
more invested in the will they won't
they of like Beast Boy being so
interested in her and and like I thought
it was interesting that everybody does
make it even Damien makes attempts to
extend the olive branch and to try and
you know give her opportunities to talk
and open up like I love that continuity
of the maturity that has come through
and the diamond door it'll break you
metaphor beautiful and well delivered
like that moment was really well like
she literally got torn apart instead of
becoming a diamond yeah and that's a
great theme for for especially a younger
you know set of characters you know to
go through something where yeah you know
sometimes it's just too much and that's
a part of life too and you can't maybe
circumvent or overcome all the
circumstances or all the hurt all the
pain and I thought her backstory was
really unsettling and and gripping and
and dark but yeah it just seemed like
they needed for my viewership experience
yeah to have the levels of investment I
would have wanted I would have wanted to
root for the relationship between her
and Beast Boy from a real genuine
emotional Place rather than just like ah
you know be fun for them to get together
but yeah the way they play that I mean
I'm like I don't know if I would be
right welcoming of these advances like I
was genuinely rooting for Raven and
everyone in the first movie but I was I
was rooting for those relationships and
they're rooting for like her and Damian
maybe like uh ship them a little bit and
like that was real like you felt that
like yeah like so I don't know I I just
I think like there was a little bit
missing from the first one yeah this had
some of the Teen like again because that
first one too had a special kind of teen
Nuance of its tone and its voice where
it does feel different than something
for kids versus something for just
adults you know like I thought they
still maintained some of that sure
um
are not enough frankly that's that's
where they lost me they did a little
Polaroid of it yep that helped
um it mostly worked yeah no it's it's
yeah it's it it was a it was fun it was
it was nice it pretty much worked it
just yeah it just could have been more
flavorful it could be more Rich you know
I agree but I certainly had a good time
with it really glad to have seen it I
really like all these characters I'm
excited to see more of these characters
I assume there are more Teen Titans
episodes
um but yeah for now that one is uh my
lower half not the bottom I don't know
what the bottom is but like where you
know as we approach I think this was
like 14 something like that so as we you
know as we approach uh go into our
second dozen it'll be curious to see how
this all Stacks up but uh you know this
was 2017 I don't know if we're gonna say
on the dcau but if we do we're going to
be approaching the present as we power
through very excited to see what we're
doing next please like Please Subscribe
if you're not please leave a comment
below let us know what you thought of
the Judas contract let us know if
there's any other that you're excited
for us to see and uh as always love
reading those comments you guys great I
love I love how much you guys enjoy
watching us watch these hundo P yeah all
right before we skip dads you want to
shout somebody out let's do it
and now for a very special Patron shout
out to flev Doran
flev is a name that implies a certain
mysticism there's a there's an impish
almost fairy-like nature there's like I
can see like either a leprechaun or a
fairy like something in the in the
Woodland magic in flev yeah and then
Doran sounds like the name of a long
running tribe of whatever that species
is whatever you know if it's a
leprechaun or a fairy or any sort of
mischievous little imp the dorians are
like an aged race they've been here in
this Kingdom running things for good or
ill is up to you but flev door and feels
like it's a name of repute oh sure no no
flev certainly would would Rule and act
with benevolence he's got a lot of
enthusiasm because he's a very uh uh
chipper kind of guy yeah in my internet
reaction interactions with I've always
positive but sure I just wanted to give
him the option I mean if you want to
take a heel turn go ahead it's right
there it's on the tape I think it would
be very interesting to watch I think I
mean there's a lot of mischievous
creatures and that could be for an
overall good for kyusho quite you know
the playful in the ambitionist
if you will you got options if you want
to go Shakespearean with it uh I feel
like flev is a good person but if you
want to make some choices you make those
choices fluff I think that's going to do
it for uh for this episode of break down
that name
tune in next time patrons you we are
very appreciated we will see you very
soon much love